foreign
a new podcast called The Witch Trials of
JK Rowling examines The Life and Times
of the Harry Potter author focusing in
particular on her efforts to defend the
reality of biological sex and the insane
backlash she's received because of that
now I haven't listened to the series
myself so I'll just read uh I'll read
for you this very objective explainer by
CNN because they they are explaining
what the series is
is what CNN says this is not labeled as
an opinion article by the way for years
JK Rowling one of the best-selling
authors of all time has made
inflammatory comments about transgender
people particularly trans women using
dehumanizing language and baselessly
accusing them of harming cisgender women
her words have disappointed Legions of
Harry Potter fans and even the stars who
brought Rowling's book to life now a
podcast called The Witch Trials of JK
Rowling indicates that she'll discuss
the reaction to those anti-trans
comments in addition to discussing her
journey as an author with host Megan
Phelps Roper a high-profile former
member of the anti-lgbtq Westboro
Baptist Church even before its release
the podcast was met with criticism by
lgbtq advocates for seemingly siding
with Rowling based on the title alone
well all right then at least CNN clearly
isn't taking sides or maybe they are but
it's okay because Rowling is a dangerous
figure prone to making outrageous
comments such as the claim that you know
biological sex exists and that women
don't have penises the threat she poses
is so severe that the news media must
drop even the pretense of objectivity
when reporting on her though In fairness
these days they also feel the need to
drop the pretense of objectivity when
reporting on literally anything else
but what sort of threat does Rowling
pose exactly you know they know that
she's a horrible person they know that
she's dangerous they know that she's a
raging bigot
but how do they know this
like why do they think this
and and how is rallying actually wrong
about anything she said on the subject
of biological sex and transgenderism
these are questions that the media
doesn't spend very much time trying to
Grapple with I mean why bother
explaining why someone is bigoted when
you can simply accuse them of bigotry
and just leave it at that why bother
explaining how they're wrong when you
can again simply accuse them a bigotry
and leave it at that this has been their
General strategy of course
when it comes to most people but one
Intrepid reporter Monica Hess of the
Washington Post has decided to tread the
the perilous road that few journalists
dare to go down so she has listened to
the entire Witch Trials podcast uh
looking for specific evidence that
Rowling is a transphobe and she reports
her findings in a piece titled quote
listening to The Witch Trials of JK
Rowling is exhausting work a podcast
promised Clarity from Harry Potter
author and how she feels about trans
issues but it falls to the audience to
fact check her
reading a bit from the article it says
listening to The Witch Trials of JK
Rowling is exhausting it's exhausting
because it requires constant vigilance
and it's exhausting because the phrase
constant vigilance I've just realized
entered my own lexicon via Mad Eye Moody
A beloved Harry Potter character because
Rowling is brilliant is a brilliant and
beloved Storyteller who is astonishingly
good at entering lexicons manipulating
language and telling fantasy stories
it's how she became famous it's why
events surrounding Rowling these past
few years have felt like a god-awful
mess
so this is a grown adult woman who
writes professionally and yet has
admitted that she learned an extremely
common phrase from a Harry Potter book
in fact she seems to think that this
phrase that has probably appeared in ten
thousand books was invented by JK
Rowling
which is just her way of confessing that
she's never read any books but the Harry
Potter series
and and that does that does help to put
the anti-ralling Panic into a important
context it's an important thing to
understand that many of Rowling's most
hysterical critics have only ever read
the Harry Potter books along with you
know maybe potentially the Twilight
series so they consider it an
unconscionable betrayal
because they discovered that the author
of the only books they've ever read has
beliefs that differ from their own so
this to them this is like it's like
finding out that your father is living a
secret life with another family across
town they just couldn't process it
they had very very carefully constructed
a bubble for themselves owing only
allowing themselves to be exposed to
opinions and ideas that they already
agree with just to then find out that
the woman who wrote their favorite books
and the only books as far as they're
concerned belongs outside the bubble
she had infiltrated the bubble she was
an intruder
perhaps that's why Monica Hass is so
exhausted
in fact just listening to the podcast is
exhausting she says it's exhausting work
but she's not just exhausted by podcasts
she's also exhausted by reading tweets
later in the piece she writes this quote
Rowling tweets are exhausting they're
exhausting because they require constant
vigilance because they're not screaming
out obvious bigotry Allah I hate trans
people rather they're Whispering a
curated plausible deniability the kind
that purports to be just asking
reasonable questions with simple answers
well I don't doubt that I I do doubt
rather that there are
um any roofers or construction workers
or guys who work on oil rigs reading a
Washington Post article complaining
about a JK Rowling podcast but if there
are I'd love to see how they react to
this woman claiming that her job is
exhausting
because it involves reading tweets and
listening to podcasts
one can just imagine Monica Hess of the
Washington Post covered in a soot from
from you know working in the Tweet Minds
all day holding her lunch pail punching
out driving home collapsing on the couch
and utter exhaustion muscles aching
barely able to move after an exhausting
day reading JK Rowling tweets
at least that's what she wants you to
imagine
you'll you'll notice that uh that the
leftists that they're endlessly
complaining about their own exhaustion
and it's not because they're doing
anything physically demanding or doing
anything at all in general but rather
because it's it's the emotional strain
as they would put the emotional labor of
constantly encountering the traumatic
reality that other people exist
and and they have their own opinions and
beliefs about the world and those
opinions and beliefs sometimes fall
outside of the opinions and beliefs box
that the left has set up for us
this is what exhausts them so much
they are exhausted to discover that they
can't directly control what everyone in
the world thinks and says
but exhausting as this all may be we
still haven't gotten to the point
um Hess has set out to prove that JK
Rowling is bigoted and transphobic
that's that's what she's looking for
she's looking for evidence of that
she knows it's there she can feel it but
she wants she wants to lay eyes on it
does she well it's complicated she
writes quote is JK Rowling transphobic
that's what I was listening to the
podcast to begin with it promised that
Rowling would speak with unprecedented
Candor and depth about the controversy
surrounding her surrounding her from
book bans to debates on gender and sex
since 2020 Rowling's status as a
celebrated liberal and literary icon has
taken a nosedive because of tweets and
references that supporters of trans
rights view as transphobic but that
Rowling says are merely trying to
protect women and girls you might have
seen a recent column written by a
British writer named E.J uh Rosetta
Rosetta claimed to have been assigned a
piece called 20 transphobic JK Rowling
quotes were done with but said that
after months of research she hadn't been
able to find a single one rallying
according to Rosetta was saying there
are downsides that I feel should be
discussed not I hate trans people
there truly is the whole issue in a
nutshell if you're a bar for bigotry
requires Rowling to say out loud I hate
trans people then that bar will never be
cleared even if Rowling feels that way I
doubt she'd ever say it that way even
conservative pundits know not to say it
that way there is simply nothing to be
strategically gained by uttering such an
obviously prejudiced sentence
so is JK Rowling transphobic then well
Monica goes on and on and on and on back
to the article she says is JK Rowling
transphobic journalism is a business for
sticklers reporters are discouraged from
calling anyone transphobic or homophobic
or racist but they are it's they're
discouraged from doing that that's
that's literally all they do
um anyway because doing so requires
knowing what's in their hearts well the
only thing we can know with certainty is
what comes out of their mouths so what I
can say is that what comes out of her
mouth or goes onto her Twitter account
has a fuzzy Aura of harmful rhetoric
rallying might indeed believe that she
has transgender friends but take it as a
whole her body of communication on the
issue such as the things she chooses to
retweet in the provocative language she
uses while doing so cumulatively it
sucks
I do not know what is in Rowling's heart
but reading her Twitter feed this is the
overall effect her Twitter feed does not
ask its readers to think it asks them to
fear it creates phobias of trans people
it creates transphobias
okay so translation
all that JK Rowling has ever done when
it comes to this issue is simply assert
the existence of biological reality
Monica Hess cannot coherently explain
why that is bigoted or transphobic uh to
you know to Simply believe in reality
why is that bigger she can't explain it
but she's just sure that it is
even if rallying statements aren't
hateful they still have the fuzzy Aura
of harmful rhetoric there's the aura
there you have to watch out for the
fuzzy Aura she said
and this all goes to show of course that
literally anyone who contradicts the
leftist doctrine on any topic especially
this one but not just this one will be
accused of hate and bigotry and branded
as dangerous and as a violent threat to
the lives of marginalized people Etc
this will happen there is no way of
disagreeing with these people there is
no way of presenting your arguments that
will not lead to this conclusion
even if you carefully avoid saying
anything that could reasonably be
construed as bigoted it doesn't matter
because these people are not concerned
about reasons and they are not
reasonable
you can avoid blunt and harsh language
you can do all that but even then
you will still give off the fuzzy Aura
of bigotry
which is all the more reason
to never spend even one second worried
about what labels these people put on
you there is no sense in trying to couch
your rhetoric or soft pedal it
because we are all raging bigots the
moment we walk outside of the box
remember there's the box that they have
set up for us they want everybody in it
if you walk outside of it that's it
our existence is an affront to people
like Monica has
and of course it's also very exhausting
but it's not exhausting for me to say
that uh Monica Hess in the Washington
Post are for all these reasons today
cancel
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]